now the doram probe is now officially a
criminal probe it is ongoing the
Attorney General Wow his comments that
we played last night he intends to
restore faith that America's premier
institutions thank God
these men and women deserve better than
this homeys behavior will not be
tolerated justice will be served here
with reaction Senate Judiciary Committee
Chairman Lindsey Graham senator first
let me applaud you for a great job today
I know a lot of Americans if they watch
fake news CNN and all these other
channels they might not have seen the
great job you did because they only run
things that are anti Trumble right well
that's okay you can get you can live
without seeing me but you can't live
with a lie so James Comey has done more
damage to the FBI than anybody since
Jaggu ver McCabe is a category
Kristopher ray if you're watching
television you got a mountain to climb
you got to come to the Judiciary
Committee and prove to us that you're
going to change the culture at the FBI
some people need to be fired and some
people need to go to jail for what they
did because the FBI and the Department
of Justice took the law in their own
hands they defrauded the FISA Court they
trampled on the rights of Carter page
constitutional rights of American
citizens and they surveilled Donald
Trump in his campaign in my view
unlawfully for a very long period of
time the day of reckoning is coming is
not here yet
and nobody associated with this was
vindicated Comey was not a victory lap
on Monday when the first Kara you know I
got a by the way let me stay on
Christopher a a second he has not shown
any urgency he has not shown the urgency
that is needed to get to the bottom of
this resolve this and make sure it never
happens again and I'll tell you why it's
personal for me senator my mother was a
prison guard
she worked 16-hour shifts for years and
years and years my dad was a Family
Court probation guy he worked two jobs
most of my extended family were NYPD
cops
little known fact about Sean Hannity 19
or 20 I was appointed to the New York
Police Department a canapé have no idea
why they even approved me two of two
members of my family were dating they
were FBI guys one of them is
live today and he is more angry about
this but for all the hard work risk he
is taken for his country it and this is
what I'm hearing from everybody in law
enforcement well so James Comey is one
of the most arrogant conceited people
I've ever met in government to suggest
that this report vindicated him is just
an affront to the report to suggest that
everything was done properly with the
FISA warrant process regarding Carter
page insults our intelligence and mr.
Horowitz did their country a great
service as to director a people asked me
to have confidence in him yeah but you
got a really hard job director you've
got to come to the Jewish jury committee
and convinced Republicans and Democrats
you're gonna fix this crap if not he
needs to get out of the way that's my
honest assessment here okay you heard
the comments of the inspector general
today I thought they were powerful and
they added clarity to his report he also
was working within a bubble both both
prosecutor Durham and the Attorney
General bar their comments I do not
believe senator would be made but for
knowledge that they have that we don't
have that this is far deeper and more
far worse than anybody knows and it has
taken them overseas to Italy Great
Britain and other places where do you
imagine this ends up because I can't see
this ending up any other way but people
being indicted and going to jail well
all I can tell you is that Durham is
looking at whether or not there's
criminality here we know that Klein
Smith the FBI lawyer in charge of the
Pfizer process altered it email from the
CIA saying that basically Carter Page
was a source he altered the email to say
he was not and that was a very big deal
I don't know what Durham's going to
eventually do but based on his statement
Monday I would be worried if I were a
lot of the people who involved in
crossfire hurricane if you're involved
in crossfire hurricane your day of
reckoning may be coming I trust Durham
but as to Horowitz what did we learn
today you can have a newspaper article
and that can be the basis to open up a
counterintelligence investigation the
standard is incredibly low but we also
learned from mr. Hall
was once this investigation was opened
it became a criminal enterprise and
conspiracy to defraud the FISA Court to
trample on the rights of Carter page and
to basically illegally surveil Donald
Trump the reason they never briefed
President Trump defensively about the
threats coming from Russia is they did
not want to protect Trump they wanted to
destroy Trump from the day he got
elected until this thing was over the
people in charge at the highest levels
were out to get this guy to protect us
from President Trump
they didn't believe he was legitimate
and they were doing everything they
could at every opportunity to keep it
going
to try to catch him and finally they
sent an FBI agent in an interview that
was supposed to be an intelligence
interview and intelligence assessment
and intelligence briefing and the FBI
agent there was there to basically spy
on general Flynn and the president that
should scare everybody the way he set up
general Flynn meeting Comey was
despicable repulsive over 33 year
veteran and bragging about it I will say
this we end up losing FISA as a result
of this we will be less safe and when
you man Devin Nunez say the same thing
that concerns me in the safety of this
country great job senator I know you
stayed up won this thing mr. Rosen Stein
get ready to testify okay senator Graham
thank you